[Music]
hey everyone welcome to Harry Potter
theory today I'm going to be discussing
a topic that I saw requested in the
comment section quite a bit and that is
what are the Patronus animals of the
main characters and what do they mean
I'll start by explaining what exactly a
Patronus is when a witch or wizard casts
expecto patronum or the Patronus charm
it will cast a Patronus expecto patronum
is typically used to ward off Dementors
and in fantastic beasts we are informed
that the Patronus is also used to ward
off the left folds in most circumstances
the Patronus charm will generally appear
as white vapor however in some instances
expecto patronum will produce a silvery
white animal shape which is known as a
corporeal Patronus conjuring a corporeal
Patronus is considered to be a greater
feat than can during a standard Patronus
charm and is generally the sign of a
powerful witch or wizard
it is generally unachievable by young
witches or wizards but was achieved by
harry in only his third year of magical
studies as i mentioned earlier a
Patronus is generally produced to ward
off Dementors the reason that it is so
effective at this is because the
Patronus is a positive energy force that
represents everything that Dementors are
the Patronus represents hope happiness
survival and purity as the Patronus does
not fill despair or hopelessness as a
human might the Dementors can't hurt it
and they are repelled by its presence
the Patronus is also used as a
communication device a notable example
of this being when Snape uses Patronus
to guide Harry to the Sword of
Gryffindor in the Forest of Dean
each witch or wizard who is able to
produce a corporeal Patronus will
produce an animal that is uniquely tied
to them when initially casting the
corporeal Patronus the witch or wizard
will have no idea what animal they're
conjuring until they've done it for the
first time there is no explanation for
how a certain Patronus animal is tied to
a witch or wizard it is speculated that
the shape of the Patronus produced is
significantly influenced by the
personality of the caster and so when we
see characters with the same Patronus
harry and his father Snape and Lily
Potter we can infer that they had
similar personality types it is worth
noting that the corporeal Patronus of a
wizard can actually change according to
life event a notable example of this is
when the corporeal Patronus of Tonks
changes
to a dog after Sirius Black dies the
Patronus is recognized as an extension
of the identity of a witch or wizard
which means that in many cases you will
know who is trying to contact you
through their Patronus alone if the
animal shape of the Patronus is
determined by the personality of the
caster then we can only assume that the
characteristics of this person displays
our characteristics that they share in
common with the animal I'm not going to
cover the Patronus of every character
but let's look at a few number one harry
potter harris petronas animal is a stag
which is coincidentally the same
petronas as his father james he saw it
for the first time during the Dementor
attack with Hermione and Sirius at the
Great Lake James
Harry's father was an animagus and could
also shape-shift into a stag number two
Severus Snape Snape spat Ronis animal is
a doe which is actually the female form
of the stack which is Harry and James
Potter's Petronas the DOE is also the
Petronas of Lily Potter whom we know
Snape was in love with for nearly his
whole life
number three Dumbledore Dumbledore's
patronesses a Phoenix we first see
Dumbledore's Petronas which he uses as a
means of communication when he wanted to
summon Hagrid it is no surprise that
Dumbledore's Patronus is a Phoenix given
that his loyal companion Fox is also a
Phoenix number 4 Hermione Granger her
Minds Patronus is an otter which is
actually author JK Rowling's favorite
animal
Hermione learned to conjure her petronas
during the time that harry was training
them all those are me number 5 Ron
Weasley
Ron's Petronas is a Jack Russell terrier
which is interesting about Ron's
Patronus is that Jack Russell Terriers
are known for their love of chasing
officers this is fitting given that he
ended up with Hermione number 6 Minerva
McGonagall McGonagall Patronus is a cat
as we know McGonigle is an animagus that
is able to turn into a cat herself the
Patronus of an animagus often seems to
match whatever animal it is that the
witch or wizard turns into I actually
just went on Pottermore and took the
discover your Patronus quiz myself my
Patronus turned out to be a west
highland terrier
I think this means I'm possessive
determined and very aware of my
surroundings
dings what is your Patronus leave it
down in the comment section below with
that I bid you farewell and remember
help will always be given at Hogwarts to
those who ask for it
[Music]